[Music]
now to our coronavirus coverage
following several reports of lower
numbers these past few days
our state unfortunately set a new single
day record for covid death
71 in the past 24 hours more than 1100
new infections as well
of those additional deaths 2061 i should
say occurred in clark county
where we claim about 800 of the new
cases as well more than 181 000 people
have recovered from the virus in clark
county
89.3 percent of all reported cases
the southern nevada health district
today shared more information about its
covet 19 vaccine distribution plan
pharmacies today began to administer the
vaccine for residents 70 years of age or
older
those interested need to make an
appointment online they're urging
everyone to be patient while limited
doses are available
and encouraging all nevadans to think
about the seniors they know to make sure
they understand how to make an
appointment
we are seeing a sustained
trend that would would
indicate that we are we're moving
in the right direction here regarding
this um
regarding the virus in the case right
here in the state of nevada
and that is a that is a positive side uh
we're still waiting on some additional
analysis and information to confirm that
anyone who receives the vaccine will be
required to wait 15 minutes before
leaving to ensure there are no immediate
side effects
smith's pharmacy one of those locations
giving out modernist shots to seniors
again you are required to make that
appointment you can do so on the smith's
website
those slots are being opened week by
week based on how many vaccines each
location receives
we're told that should be about 100 each
week there are 45 smith's locations in
our state
37 here in southern nevada